Almost all of these pictures are taken by a spacecraft with telescopes on board,...
...which either flew past the planet, or orbited it, or landed on the surface of that planet.
The images originate with missions that range from...
...the Lunar Orbiter series of the '60s, those were the earliest pictures here, to...
...really cutting-edge shots from Saturn and Mars, from probes that are still working today.
Basically, what I did is I went in and I served as curator of a vast number of images.
I searched through hundreds of thousands of raw frames from Voyager and Viking, and so forth.
The Viking was a Mars orbiter of the '70s and '80s,...
...looking for the extraordinary shots.
I also have an eye for abstraction, I have to confess and I like pictures that...
...subvert expectation a bit.
This is a global dust storm on Mars...
...and it's comprised of about 90 individual frames...
...from the Viking orbiter of the late '70s, early '80s.
Mars is the only planet that we know that has global storms...
...and so, this is, I think, a really good example of that,...
...and I find that it has an almost biblical fury.